protest double standard so i tweeted  about this trucker convoy coming to the  united states would the pro-truck people  have the same view of black lives matter  illegally blocking traffic as they do of  the truckers doing it and obviously they  would not  these are the law and order people who  say you must always follow the rules no  matter what we have to bring back law  and order  law is the most important thing and of  course blocking traffic and closing down  bridges is against the law and when  black lives matter  even blocked an intersection for 10  minutes they would say arrest these  people and all of this different stuff  but now it's the truckers and it's  different  why is it different well it's different  because the truckers are protesting  something that doesn't exist the pro the  truckers are coming to the u.s to  protest biden's vaccine mandate  which doesn't exist because it's already  been struck down by the supreme court do  you think they have any idea